hey guys it's Justine and of here with
RO hello today we are celebrating the
release of a new phone by Samsung Oh
party party party party party party
party at this point I know you guys are
probably seen a million unboxings
because a lot of you got it early I did
not but I just got my pre-order in oh
yeah and I brought it over to Rose house
because I thought I wanted to show you
this phone and just have your reaction
to it oh my gosh I love this but I come
to ROH reacts I have the technology
phones though - yes they came out with a
bunch of different phones oh there are
different colors they are yeah this
one's a little pool and this has 20
ultra which is actually their higher end
line so this shoots in 8k and you know
what shut up yes so 8k on your freaking
phone you're gonna it's like you're
gonna see through my soul you're going
to yeah you can't even see my pores
you're gonna see through me I mean how
can you get more than 4k I don't film
before okay because the file size is
humongous it's only video size is this
big that are in 4k is what I'm here
shooting with you oh wow no if I wasn't
telling you right now that this wasn't
4k you wouldn't know yeah
is this 4k or not this is what I would
we were just
April fooling you the thing that I think
you would like about shooting in 4k and
still editing in a 1080 timeline is okay
what I love punching in to get like
exceptions and silly things yeah you
can't hide it wouldn't have much quality
loss so you'd be able when you punch in
yes because you're still shooting in a
tentative timeline Wow but shooting in
4k you'll have so much more to work with
when you're ready okay a little upgrade
let me know am I going to make a whole
video about it a whole series so there's
like a
Oh an ultra-wide angle at a zoom and
this is something it was incredible they
did a demo at the press event you can do
a hundred X zoom in a photo like a
hundred how far away that is so this is
point five this is a wide angle so you
can see a rose incredible setup which it
is look at these light awesome
this is 4x oh my gosh so here's 10
here's 30x
look how zoomed in you could see I mean
you can I can see your oh my gosh look I
can see your new my blender over there
blue the quiet one there it is a key see
a gun yep oh my gosh and what I like the
Samsung as daring is they're really kind
of pushing that technology forward like
look this is the hundred X does not look
that incredible like it's not like wow
this is an impressive zoom lens like
this is something that really is
impossible to get you can still get the
shot it doesn't look great but you can
still do it you can still see it mm-hmm
you can get it it's literally a little
8k video here which will be downgraded
to 1080 but yes I want to show you guys
rose set up because it's no good it is
you've got your light hmm we have two
little quino's in the corners my light
off of the ceiling and then we have two
big quino's in front of us which
counteract cuz we're backlit we are
completely backlight cuz this is my real
backyard outside and so if you don't
have the big quino's in the front we are
so dark we're like shadowed you can you
can't even make out our faces even when
you bump the brightness on the camera
yeah it's it's major shadow it looks
like I have like a beard they make it so
even if you're filming at night still
looks like it's daytime yeah it's crazy
if you can put them outside the thing
with this too is it is anyway George is
that gonna take up well you can ask me
to video this phone up to 1.5 terabytes
of storage they also have a feature
where you couldn't do quick share now so
it's kind of like airdrop for Android
Mike's gonna want this now it shoots an
8k he's gonna be like we can just film
with that when we do vlogs and stuff
see you over there or PC they also have
a pink s20 that came out I was home Hank
it's a beautiful color
yes look at this color oh that's pretty
oh I know it's a good color yeah feels a
little baby blue basically like the
color of my shirt right now dear
designers whoever picked this color I
approve the beautiful great color this
is beautiful I just wish they made it in
the higher versions this is the lower
end model but they only have it in yeah
oh it's like a limited color thing yeah
but it's okay I'm struggling with it but
yeah we have blueberry muffin everybody
okay so I have two dogs who have cookie
who he saw and then this is blueberry
muffin well this could actually be a
good test to try out this thing that
they have on here it's called a single
shot and what's cool
oh sorry single cake single take this is
on because this will basically shoot
like a 10-second clip and it'll give you
a bunch of content out of that okay what
do I do
okay it's autos gross clean as my gum
okay let's bring the puppy in tree then
it will it will love the puppy okay wait
wait me okay so don't look at it this is
so great so it'll give us like a little
video
[Music]
and then it gives you like different
ones so this is the one that if thought
would be the best I'm not sure if that's
like the best face that you've ever made
I think it's a winner winner it's you
know oh my gosh look it's a little bra
as well that's cute
it like spun look it gives you a couple
different options so this is kind of fun
if you're just like also if you just a
minute and it can make a bunch of
different media's from that yeah what's
it called again it's called single tape
here is the although we did it before
just being silly I think I like this one
better actually it's good I mean it's
great look at that an ad the beauty
filter and everything orange Thank You
Samsung a lot of times when I go to take
a selfie on samsung phones I'm good
because the beauty filters yeah it's
really fun obviously I'm such a huge i
phone fan but like I still always have a
secondary Android phone so the secondary
film that I have been using has actually
been this one ooh the one in another
color yeah this I found that called Z
flip so what's cool about this is it
freakin folds it shut up full like look
at this I thought you were breaking your
phone I thought you were going crack I
was like I mean I'm not that strong
what's crazy about this is they
developed this very thin sheet of glass
and it's really pretty impressive so
they had the Galaxy fold that folded
like this way before but then they just
recently came out with this and I didn't
think that I was actually gonna like it
as much as I do and I really like it yes
okay how aggressive can you be with this
flip you can beep I mean good no I
haven't really given it like an
aggressive I'm kind of wondering like
can I be ro in high school cuz ro in
high school had a cellphone that flip
clothes meet you and when I was like I'm
mom and now be like and I love that was
so satisfying like that sound in the
call I got that so satisfying
I'm so sad I certified up to about two
hundred thousand folds okay the color is
cool it's a great color I want to show
you something else it's really cool when
you double tap the power button which
also by the way a double that's a
fingerprint sensor do not tell me I
can't I can't hear us and you hit the
volume button are you kidding me and it
takes a picture this is taking a picture
hello opens up already
that's us like look how cool like feel
it you can definitely feel the crease I
I'm knocking it would be annoying I
don't like you don't even realize it's
there
like I wanted to be that person that's
like I see the crease this is annoying I
don't like it but I couldn't be that
person because it didn't really affect
me much at all you have a food setting
very important Samsung does do a really
great job of having like different auto
setting everybody I know takes pictures
of their food so I like that there's a
food setting I wanted to show you
YouTube really quick before we show me
show me anything else on here so what's
neat about this it's all right let's see
here
I was like I figured we'll probably have
a new video out I tested my dog's IQ oh
my gosh and what's great is hold it shut
up yeah so you can be like scrolling
down here and watching the video up here
are you guys seeing this this they
probably have already seen it but you
can school here I just love how excited
you are about this is Laura like a mini
laptop yeah like the smallest little
laptop like look it's my size oh my gosh
Justine look at me do I look like I'm
like on my little laptop it also reminds
me of like a compact like a makeup
mirror type thing it is it's that size
you it looks like you're just like so
when we go into the camera setting oh
sorry it's still in the food settings I
got really excited that you flip that up
and it basically it's like a little
tripod which is kind of neat and this is
really neat I didn't realize for your
pictures there's a tripod right so you
can film yourself it has just your shut
ah
so if I poke a oh oh so oh shoot still
going if you put your hands down
okay so it has gesture control so if you
start waving at it like it'll start the
timer ready okay ready it's really fun I
like that I like this phone so much more
than I thought that I would it's really
fun it's fun like just I really really
like it this could be great for tic TOCs
the other day I was missing you tic toc
as I have been doing and I follow you on
tic toc I was going fall like 10 people
I was going crazy actually
show it to you let me see I want to see
what you've been up to you how do you
get my other phone sorry
[Music]
but what I was doing missile inside they
were like they didn't even faze it I
said just making a tick-tock to like
yeah that's what we thought I was like
I'm so glad that we're it in time that I
can be weird and do weird things and
they're okay with it so fast in the end
oh just think oh so I guess that's
really it I just wanted to show these to
you I love bringing over new tech and
shone into so what do you think I love
it
I'm really into this I am um I want to
know when this screen will give out I
will let you know but it looks really
good and I actually don't mind the
little bump there either yeah it's not
really that big of a deal oh it's so
little I know it's very minor and it's
so satisfiying okay thank you so much
for watching bro thank you so much for
lending your reaction to the new Samsung
phones this is so cool if you guys have
anything that you would like me to bring
to show ro tech-wise I wouldn't got a
lot of really cool thing to say I think
you'd be into so yeah let us know in the
comments below let her know I want to
learn about everything make sure you
guys also go check out ROS channel we
have so many videos that we've made
together in the past but I hope all of
her links in the description below and
that's it the videos over that's it
[Music]